Yeah, good morning everyone, I am Nilanjan, a PhD research scholar from CCD's department
IIT Kharagpur.
And today I am going to explain you about LLM fine tuning and how genetic workflows is
performed in our computer science department and all.
And we will understand that how these large language models can be prompted properly so
that you can utilize them for your different purposes, maybe in an industry environment
or in a research environment.
So there are different aspects the LLMs are used today as you all know of.
So before starting I am just going to give you some general idea about the different
things that we will require today.
So the first thing that we will require is the Google collab link or a GitHub link that
I have provided to you, I think you will get it in the chat and also you can go ahead and
get to my GitHub account, which is github.com/nilanjanesb and here you will get the LLM prompting
underscore fine tuning this particular page where you will have these two files available
to you.
So my recommendation will be you can try to use this and do it alongside with me whenever
I am running and you will have some issue you can just let me know.
The second thing that will require is a hugging face library.
So you go to huggingface.com basically it is huggingface.co and once you go there you
will have to create your own account and using that account you can log in and you can create
different tokens that will discuss that how we are going to use these tokens in our program
and all.
So what is hugging face is basically it provides you lots of different infrastructures and
libraries for this different DL tasks which are basically related to large language models.
So if you are working with large language models probably we will end up with hugging
face any of the time so it is a very important library in that sense.
So it also provides you with datasets, it provides you with different kinds of data structures,
it also provides you with some models like transformers which you can use to load different
large language models or upload different large language models.
Here you will also get different places where you can just test a large language model so
they have implemented the language model you can just prompt the model and apart from that
they also provide with some tokens.
So for example there are some language models that you cannot directly access because it
is restricted to let us say for research purpose or something like that for that you can request
access for those libraries from this hugging face account and you can create separate tokens
for it and you can use that in your code that way you will be able to access those repositories.
Another advantage of hugging face is that you can directly train a model here we are
not going to discuss that but these are some of the benefits of using hugging face.
There are some other also but we try to use hugging face in our work.
So I hope that you have got this GitHub account and link so here you will see that the first
is basically LLM zero shot prompting and the second one is LLM fine tuning.
So you can just open the first one so that we can get started.
So just before starting I am just going to give you a general idea of what is a large
language model because some of you might not be familiar with it.
So the first thing is for a large language model which is very important is that we require
huge amount of resources because training a large language model will require you big
amount of text information, text data and you have to have your high performance computation.
We will also discuss about this high performance computation because you are having some doubts
from the previous classes that we have seen so I will just clear that section also.
So once you have this big amount of training data you have high performance computation
you then have after training a foundation model.
So what is a foundation model?
A foundation model we also call it a vanilla model which is basically a very new model
architecture which is the very first architecture of a particular model and we try to train
that model.
So for example, but we can use huge amount of text data and train the model and we can
call it as a vanilla but right so there are different models for that.
So once you have this foundation model what does this foundation model does is basically
trains on huge amount of training data that contains different tasks, different kind of
domains and all right.
So it is a multi-domain foundational model we can say then there is a part which is called
fine tuning and that is one of the aspect of our today's lecture is that we are going
to fine tune a model.
So you have already a foundation model once you train it with a big amount of training
data and then you have this foundation model which is a very generalized model it does
not have much information on a particular domain but it has a generalized domain across
multiple domains.
Now we have this fine tune model, so fine tune models are basically used for adapting
to different tasks.
So for example, I am just going to make a large language model for chat purposes.
So you are in an industry and you want to create a chat bot for your customers.
For that you will need a foundation model probably the foundation model you will get
it from hugging face because many people have already trained big models and they have uploaded
it there.
So you can directly pick those models from hugging face and then you can use your training
data that you have in your hands to actually fine tune a large language model for adapting
to a different task.
So here in the diagram you can see that after this foundation model there is tuning which
is basically gives you the fine tune model.
This fine tune model you can adapt to different tasks.
So the first task is for example this chat the second one is for example the sentiment
analysis identification of documents, image captioning, direction, image identification.
So there are lots lots of different aspects that you can go ahead and use this fine tune
models for.
So as you can understand if I am in a position where I need to build a chat bot for my clients
or my customers for that I will get a foundation model from an already built model by anyone.
Then I will take that and I will have my data that I want and using that data and this foundation
model I will retrain it.
So retraining it you are going to actually change the model parameters.
So you are going to train that model for that particular task and once you do that you will
see that the model will perform much better on that particular task and that is how you
can build a chat bot for your own environment and own business.
So as you can see this is limitless you can actually use any kind of adaptation.
People are always trying out different things and fine tuning the model using different
ways.
One of the more important thing is that the fine tuning again requires you a good amount
of computation because you are again retraining a model.
It is not like that you will need the training resources like the foundation model because
it is a very, very huge model but for fine tuning you will require again a good amount
of training resources may not be that much big but yeah that is required.
Now the resource thing we will discuss because it is a very, very important thing while we
come across this large language models because we are not able to run all the models whatever
we want.
We are limited by our resources.
So today we are going to use this Google collab.
I will also expect that you will be using Google collab for this thing and if you have
a system that has a good dedicated GPU probably an NVIDIA GPU some of the AMD GPUs are also
working these days but if you have a good dedicated GPUs you can directly use notebooks
in your own local system and run the exact same code.
For our thing we are very, very limited with this Google collab whatever the free version
provides because we have not used this paid version here because we know that many people
that you are working with you do not have this pro version or dedicated GPU.
So this is a free version and probably all of you will get this free version and here
they give you a T4 GPU access for these models and the T4 GPU is not very powerful but it
is much better than using a central processing unit or CPU for any kind of LLM task.
So I think this image is clear.
So let us move on to the very first thing that is known as zero shot prompting.
Now before moving to zero shot prompting I am just going to tell you what is prompting.
So what is the term prompt?
The term prompt actually represents the input that you are giving to a model.
So it represents the user input.
So whatever input you give to the model you ask the model that becomes your prompt and
we will see that how the prompt can be structured and how there are different ways of using
this prompt for our own benefits.
So very easily we can actually implement these models.
So let us just first start using the transformers library.
Now this transformers library I am just going to show you if you just go.
So you will see that this transformers library is again provided by Hugging Face.
So this is a library that probably you will use most of the time for loading a large language
model and its organizers.
So you can see that if you go into this page you will see that there are different ways
that how you can use this like transformers it can be used for pipelining basically you
can use an existing model that you have you load that model and you can just prompt it
directly.
You can train the model using this pipeline so fine tuning or training a model is possible
using this and you can generate basically you want to get some output from a prompt
and you can do that using this generate function.
So you see that how that can be installed using different systems and how you can do
that is probably given here in this installation and you can just go here and see that which
environment you are using and how you can actually install this.
So I will recommend that you if you are using a local system you will use pip and for Google
collab I believe that it already has this transformers library if it is not we can install
it anyways.
So let us just start it and before starting just let us see what are the different classes
that we are using for that.
So the very first model that we are going to use is known as Flan T5 Excel.
So I have selected this model because it is a fairly small model it is a very very small
model and how so if you just go to search Google using this Flan T5 Excel model you
will see that this is a sequence to sequence model and you can just open this page in the
hugging face library and you will see that this particular model details are given here.
So there is a dedicated research paper on that also you can just grab that and study
that how these models are fine tuned and perform.
So most of the things that you require are provided here only so you do not need to bother
with them most of the time.
So this is the language model that we are going to use.
This model provides you with three different variants as I can remember.
So it has this smaller model this they can again a larger model basically we call it
as Flan T5 large then we have this Flan T5 extra large and there is another big model
which is a 12 billion parameter model and this the version that we are using is a 3
billion parameter model.
So it is not very small model it is not the biggest model in the open source community.
So generally you will see that the models are around 7 billion and 8 billion parameters.
Now what is this parameters right?
So this is the term that I have used many times in this 10, 15 minutes.
So the parameters actually define how big your model is and these are very important.
So these parameters are basically neurons that the model is trained on.
So once you have these neurons being trained by the model these neurons actually create
the capability of this model.
So generally you will see that if you have a higher billion parameter model higher dimensional
model then you will get a good outcome from that model.
So for example the GPT models generally the GPT 4, GPT 3 they have not disclosed the parameters
but it is probably extending 1 trillion parameters so it is expected.
So you can see that if we increase the number of parameters the models performance gets
increased.
So the data that is dependent on the model the training resources is dependent on a model
alongside that the model that we are using the parameters of the models are also dependent
alongside the architecture of the model.
So this is Flan T5 Excel and just to give you a general idea this Flan T5 Excel model
you can see here that it is fine tuned already using different tasks.
So generally when you are downloading a model you are not downloading the base model.
You are already downloading an instruction tuned model.
So what is instruction tuned model is basically a model that has been already fine tuned for
different tasks.
So this model this Flan T5 Excel that you are going to get from Hugging Face is already
instruction fine tuned.
So if you give it some instruction it will be able to follow those instructions.
It is having a chain of thought fine tuning so we will discuss what is chain of thought
in a little bit but not in much detail.
So chain of thought basically means you just ask the model to explain a particular thing
that way the model will break down its output and this actually helps the model not only
you as a reader but it helps the model to break down a big problem into smaller chunks
so that it can answer it more properly.
Again this are the two different tasks again I think there is some QA task that is also
being provided.
You can see that the different fine tunings that has been gone through this model.
So we are using this model and how we are going to use this model we can see that.
So here from transformers import T5 tokenizer.
So this is a tokenizer that is provided for this T5 models.
So if you are using T5 models you will probably end up using this T5 tokenizer and T5 for
conditional generation.
So this is the model or class that loads the model.
So how this is linked if I am just going to tell you.
So if you see that there is a model in hugging phase so let us call it HF model M. So this
is the hugging phase model so you can directly access this hugging phase model using this
transformers library that we have used.
So this transformers library or API it gives you access to this models directly.
So let us say we have plan model which we can directly access from this hugging phase
model using this transformers library.
So this is the way we are actually getting this transformer model.
But we have for example a different model LAMMA.
So we can directly access that LAMMA model also.
But this transformer models actually have different types of model interfaces.
Let us call it model interfaces INT for different models.
So for model interface for plan may be different than that of LAMMA.
So that is the only change you need to make when you are coding a particular model when
you are just building a model from this hugging phase transformers library.
So we will see that how it is done.
So here you see that we have used T5 tokenizer and T5 for conditional generation.
So this kind of libraries or this kind of classes actually help us to directly get access
to the model.
Now how will we know that which model we want.
It is as simple as you just give this classes or initialize these classes with the model
name.
Let us start with the tokenizer first.
So you see that we have created a tokenizer interface tokenizer.
And we have used this T5 tokenizer class and we have given that form pretend.
So this is the function which takes the name of the model.
So you will see that for T5 conditional generation also form pretend.
So this is a particular class that actually takes the form pretend libraries.
So these are pretend models.
And once you have that you just pass the Google slash plan dash T5 dash Excel.
This is the name of the model.
So you will go to this hugging phase library and you will see that if you go here you will
get the same code that we are using.
So you see that you will get the name of the model here.
So for example Google plan T5 Excel.
So this is the name of the model.
So you give the name of the model as simple as that.
For the model we are going to use this T5 for conditional generation.
This is for the model and we again use the form pretend.
And here you will see that we have added another section which is called device map.
This is an important thing.
This is very, very important thing if you are working with LLMs and we will discuss that.
And this is the name of the model again and this is another function.
And what we will have is that we will have the tokenizer loaded in this tokenizer and
model will be loaded here.
So what is tokenizer and what is model?
We will discuss this also.
So let us run it and see that wherever this transformers library is already present in
this Google collab or not.
If it is not we just need to install it.
So let us run it and till then we just observe what is tokenizer.
So you give an input to the model using natural language text.
So a natural language text, in natural language text we are using high level languages.
So we are just for example writing hey, how are you, right, so for example we are giving
this as an input to the model.
So this is a natural language text.
So for this, for example the training output, so let us say this is a training data.
So this is a trained data when we are training a model.
So how are you?
The model should output like I am fine or something like that.
So it will give you this kind of output.
Now how are we going to train a model?
So we are going to give the model this as a training data.
So the input will be this to the model.
So let us say we are using the plan model only for now, this to the model and it will
generate some output.
What is the output?
We do not know.
But we have this expected output and we will calculate a loss out of it.
So the loss will be calculated based on this, right and we are going to back propagate this
loss.
So this kind of things probably you already know because we have already gone through
this large language model training and basically the training of different machine learning
and deep learning models.
So it is exactly the same thing, so there is nothing different.
So here the one thing that comes into play is the tokenizer library or tokenizer.
What is the tokenizer?
It actually converts this hey how are you to a different embedding form.
So embedding you have already learned in this BERT class and all in the deep learning classes.
So what you essentially do is you convert these two numbers and we call these numbers
as vectors, we call these numbers as different collection of vectors and these vectors can
be used as an input to the model.
Similarly, the model will output the vectors also.
So you do not get a natural language text directly.
So you get this tokenized input which is basically hey how are you, you are tokenizing it and
this tokenizes vectors are passed to this plan model.
The model output will again be a tokenized version of this output and you have that tokenizer
and you have to reconverted to the natural language text.
So essentially you end up with having multiple steps here.
So just let us just give you this step, so the first is this input text.
So once you have this input text, you will see that we will use this tokenizer let us
call it T to tokenize this input text and we will have a vector of this text.
This we pass to the LLM, once you pass this to the LLM, the LLM generates a tokenized
version of its output again.
Then we use the same tokenizer that we have used earlier and we pass this vectors through
this tokenizer and we get this output text.
So this is always the case for any language model, large language model that we will be
working on.
So the input that will be passed to a tokenizer, the tokenizer with converted to a vectorized
form, that vectorized form will be input to the language model, the language model will
output this vectorized form again, you will use this tokenizer and get the tokenized
natural language output.
So you see that it ran executed properly because this transformers library is already installed
in colab, so you do not have to specifically install it.
But if you need to install it anyhow, you can just go there in that hugging face transformers
library in the installation section, you will see that how it can be installed in your own
system and all.
So now we have this tokenizer, so you see that it is loading, downloading the model.
So it has downloaded this model.
So if you are using this Google colab, it will download the model every time because it is
not storing the model, it is just storing it in a directory which actually does remove
when you just cancel this particular notebook.
So you have to redownload it every time or you can keep it in Google Drive if you have
space and you can just link your Google Drive to this particular model locations.
So you see that the model is loaded right now.
So we have this tokenizer and we have this model that is loaded here.
So let us start with our first input prompt.
As we told or discussed what is prompt, prompt is basically just a conversion of like input
that we are going to give to the language model.
So it is the representation of what we want from the model.
So here this you will see in most of the examples, I have taken the exact same example in fancy
of it.
So just translate English to German.
So since this is an instruction tuned model, this has been instruction tuned to do any kind
of task that we want, even if it has not learned it.
So since it is like trained on a huge amount of data probably it will end up giving you
a good kind of result.
Now plan T5XL is a 3 billion parameter model, do not expect a very good output from it.
But it is quite good for understanding how the language model works.
So input text, you will see that we have given this in a string format, just a natural language
text.
So translate English to German.
And there is no restriction on how you are going to write that.
It can be written in any ways.
So translate English to German, how old are you?
Now you might ask like why it is English to German?
Because both uses the same Roman alphabets.
So we cannot write that converted to Bengali or something because our tokenizer is not
having that information.
So if you have a tokenizer that is trained on Hindi language or any other language, then
you can translate it using that also.
So here we are just converting it from English to German.
So the model is already seen some German text, seen some English text and how they are translated.
And the text that we are providing, we are providing it here.
And as I told you this prompt currently at this stage does not have any kind of fixed
type.
So you can write in any way.
So how old are you?
Then you can write convert the following to the English or convert it to German.
You even don't have to specify the source language also in most of the cases.
So you will see that this kind of models are very, very flexible.
Now this is the second thing.
So once we are ready with the prompt once we have this prompt, now we are going to tokenize
it.
So as I give you the pipeline that we are working on, the pipeline already had this input text
as we discussed.
Now it has this tokenized text.
Now for the tokenized text we are going to obviously use this tokenizer that we have
already initialized.
So you will see that this tokenizer object, it takes the input text, basically the prompt
that we are giving.
And there is another parameter which is the return tensor is equal to pt.
And we are getting this input.id.
So what it generally creates, it creates a set of different things from this input text.
What are the different things we are not much concerned about because we don't use those
kind of things apart from in research.
So if you are using a tokenizer, in general you are just going to get this tokenized vectors
that we were discussing.
To get the vectors you have to pass this dot input id.
So input id will give you this tokenized vectors only and nothing else.
So once we run this input text, so let's do it in a step by step way.
So this is the input prompt.
So let's run this and then tokenize it separately.
I think you can just go ahead and do it yourself using this provided links and you can just
open colab and since these models are already loading directly, you don't have to take
any care.
So one thing that you need to note is that in this part, you can see that there is something
known as t4 given here.
So this t4 means you are using this t4 gpu that is freely available to most of you.
And this t4 gpu you can use it for running these codes.
So let's just run this tokenizer part and let's see what we get.
So let's print this input id separately, see what we have.
So previously we had this input text and now we have this input id.
So this is very simple, you can see.
So this is a plain vector, this is a plain simple vector that represents the text that
we have inputted.
So the prompt is converted to its numbers and this tokenizer is trained alongside this
model.
So you have to use the tokenizer that came with your model that that's what I can say.
So once you have this tokenized input, now you will be able to generate the output from
the model.
So let's just run this again here in a separate cell, let's run it here.
So here you see that model gives you a function generate and it takes this input id.
So it is in its simplest form, you will see that generate actually takes many, many parameters
and that are that are really, really required for if you are working with large language
models.
We will go ahead and see one by one, but for now we can just see that if you just use this
generate function, it takes this input id which is enough to get you an output.
So this way you can create your own large language model.
So previously probably you have used a chat GPT model from their APIs and all, but right
now you can create your own model, your own large language model using this easy step
like four lines of codes.
So that's very, very easy.
So you see that we have this output which stores this generate functions tokens.
So let's just get the output and see what we get in the output.
But found at least two devices okay fine.
So yeah, so what is the problem with this, you will see that the problem with this is
that it is so once I run this thing, this model or generate yeah, where is the error?
Yeah.
So this is the error that we are getting right.
So this error you may find many of the time.
So let's see expected all tensors to be on the same device, but at least two devices,
this could have zero and CPU when checking argument for index in method.
So what does this tell?
So what does this mean?
This means that there are two devices that are capable of running this and we cannot
offload, we cannot offload some of the part to CPU and some of the part to GPU, right?
So this is an important observation.
So here you see that where we have given this, let's see.
So here we have given this device map equals to auto.
So it actually, so I told you that we'll discuss this parameter because it's an important parameter.
So this device map, it actually maps your device.
So whatever device is available, whatever good device is available, it will load the
model there, right?
So the main problem is that, that this device, this T5 for conditional generation, this model
LLM model is loaded into the GPU, that's fine, that's what we wanted.
But once we are using this tokenizers, this tokenizer might not load in the GPU, it might
load in the CPU and that can create a problem.
So let's see how we can solve that.
So just converting this to CPU, let's see what we get, right?
So we have already downloaded the model.
So the model will be not downloaded, re-downloaded because in this session, it is already there.
So you see that once we just ran this code, it just loaded this two checkpoints are this,
not taking much of a time, right?
So now again, we do the same thing.
We run this model.
So let's discuss one thing before we run.
Yeah, so this is very, very interesting and very, very important.
So you have to understand when you are using large language models that probably you are
having a GPU, probably you are having a graphical processing unit and also you have a CPU, central
processing unit, right?
And you have a memory of GPU which we call at VRAM, right?
And we have a memory of CPU which we call at primary memory.
So this is the RAM of the system, right?
So once we load a model, let's consider our LLM, any model it could be.
It can either be loaded entirely, what does it mean by entirely?
The tokenizer and the model both.
So that can be loaded into the CPU directly.
So the model tokenizers and model both are loaded into the primary memory or CPU we call
it.
So essentially it is loading in the primary memory.
We calling it CPU because the processing is done by CPU and the memory that it is utilizing
is the primary memory.
Or it can load it to this VRAM which is the memory from the graphics processing unit GPU.
And you can load this P and M which is essentially the model tokenizer and model directly to
the VRAM provided your VRAM is sufficient to load the model.
And the following the processing will be performed by GPU.
Now you see here in the GPU I have drawn a very big diagram.
What does this mean?
This means that the GPU has many more number of cores as compared to a central processing
unit.
So it can perform this task, this LLM based task faster than a CPU.
So we always try to load these models to a GPU and not into the CPU, right?
So what will be the problem if the model is loaded into the VRAM and the tokenizer is
loaded into this like CPU or primary memory or vice versa.
It won't work because it doesn't have that direct access from this VRAM to this primary
memory.
So they don't have this direct access.
So the GPU will use its own memory and CPU will use its own memory.
CPU cannot access this VRAM, the GPU cannot access this primary memory directly, right?
To load a model.
So this is the output that we get from a model.
So essentially we avoided one issue that we might face so we have this kind of thing.
So this is the translation because we asked the model to translate from English to German
and all.
So this is the translation that we get.
Now if I just tell you that, so if I just tell you that give me a sum of 19 and 5, so
are these language models good or not for that?
So you can understand this large language models are trained on text data.
They are not trained to identify what is plus, what is minus and all, right?
So they don't know the initial significance or the mathematical significance of this 19
plus 5.
I don't know if you agree or not.
So let's just see if this kind of things are working.
So now essentially I am giving the model in the same way.
I am just not changing anything here.
So the input text is what is the sum of 19 plus 5?
That is the sum of 19 plus 5.
And tokenize the prompt using the tokenizer again we are doing the exact same steps and
we are getting the output.
Let's see what is the output that we get.
So probably you are also running and if you are executing the code alongside me, if you
face some issue please note that so that we can discuss at the end.
So, we are running it in CPU mode right now because it's a small thing, we will just revert
back to GPU once we need a better thing.
So this is giving me output 14.
That's great because the output I required is 19 plus 5 and the model gave me the output
to be 14.
So you see that these models are very, very bad at mathematical reasonings and mathematical
operations.
It doesn't understand what 19 plus 5 should be.
Of course, you can change the prompt in some way maybe or maybe you can give some different
numbers and it might work but for most of the cases it won't work.
So this is the thing that we must know.
So we can change this behavior of the model somehow maybe.
As you can see so we are just writing this simple prompt where we are saying what is
the sum of 19 plus 5 exact same thing that we have written earlier and we are giving
it another statement provide a step by step explanation.
Now this is very, very, very important, this is very important as I told you why it is
important because you see that the model that we are using this Flantify model is actually
fine tuned for this chain of thought reasoning.
It is not a reasoning model.
We right now have different reasoning models.
I will just show you the examples of what the reasoning models are.
But in general this chain of thought fine tuning is actually part of this reasoning kind of
thing and what does it mean, it means that it will break down a bigger problem into smaller
problems that can be solved easier right or you can say that the model outputs something
and before giving it to the user it rejects it or validates it whether it is correct or
not before giving the output to the user.
So this is one of the aspect.
Let us see if using that we can resolve anything or not.
So if you see the execution criteria, so the tokenizing is very fast.
The model output generate function is the actual function that generates the output.
So this green arrow you can see here, so it takes most of the time because you are running
this input through the entire model and generating the output right and the output is again needs
to be decoded.
I forgot to like mention this part where this tokenizer dot decode function actually takes
this vectors tokenized vectors and you get the converted output basically it decodes
the output.
It is as same as this encode function.
So encode function you will encode the text from the text to this number and you can take
this number from basically the vectors and convert it to this actual values.
So yeah this is the output that we get 19 plus 5 equals to 24 that is great because just
by changing a single line I was able to actually correct this part.
And I am not sure if it will work for all the numbers and all that is not guaranteed.
But you can check that if you give different numbers using the first version whether it
works or not it might work in the first version also for some of the numbers right.
But this explanation what does it mean?
It means that it will try to check something right what it has checked you do not have much
idea.
So now let us see what it has written the sum of 19 plus 5 is 24 plus 5 equals to 27.
So it has given some generate random values but whatever may be the same we were able
to get the exact output that we wanted.
So 19 plus 5 becomes 24.
Now you see initially it just gave the output a particular number.
Now it write some reasoning it write some reasoning at least.
Now let us understand this reasoning part.
So this reasoning part what does this mean?
So let us consider this to be the LLM so this is the LLM right.
So the LLM takes this tokenized vectors this is the input this is the tokenizer and this
is the natural language text it could be anything hello right.
So this input is tokenized and we get this tokenized input and we passed it to the LLM.
This tokenized input what it does is it will be passed through this model and we will get
the output from the model in the same tokenized form as simple as that.
But if you are using this phase where you are saying the model to explain the thing
you are essentially the model is straight in such a way because it is a chain of thought
reason model it will not give you the output directly it will not give you the output directly.
Instead it will generate the output here in an intermediate state it will generate the
output in the intermediate state it will recheck it why this is the output.
So why this is the output and it will give both of this as the output both of this will
be there.
Some of the models will again go a step further ahead where this Y the output from this Y
will be again used to actually match the output.
This output matching will be performed and once this matching is performed you will see
that you might find some discrepancy.
So why this is the output or why this should be the output if you ask a question to yourself
you can get that this should not be the output maybe and the output is not matching with
the Y statement.
If it does not match you can see that this process can be repeated multiple times until
you are satisfied basically the model is satisfied to give you an output.
So there is a loop that is forming here.
So that is why this two models are there.
The first one is we are calling it as chain of thoughts model COT model which is basically
this model and it does not have this match part.
It only gives you this output and this Y part it does not match it in that sense.
But even if you are generating this Y part many times due to this Y part you are actually
able to get a better output.
So that we have already seen in our test.
So this is known as chain of thought and there are other models which we specifically call
it as the reasoning model.
Which we specifically call as reasoning model because this model has a special function which
actually matches the input and output and then finally gives you an output.
So one of the example is that GPT reasoning model.
There is the Proplexity already has this DeepSick model which is again a reasoning model.
So these models will take your input, generate output, ask itself why that output is correct
or why it is incorrect and so on.
And then it will re-verify that output and then finally once all these steps are over
it will give you an output.
So this reasoning model you will see since this is a loop kind of thing it will take
more time because it will generate multiple times, it will match it multiple times.
So a chain of thought model is a faster model but is not that reliable in good working environments
where importance is given to the output of the model.
And reasoning models while it will take more time is preferred many because it will give
you a better output.
And if you get a direct output from the model you will see that where this kind of loops
or even why is also not there you will get a random output.
And for at least tasks that are not fine tuned to the model are not understood like the mathematical
operations that we have discussed.
Now we are going to make a chat model, why this chat model is important let us see we
are using this.
So we are using a different model here.
So I am restarting this session because I am going to load a different model.
So if you are doing the same you can do that also.
Before moving on to this section I will just give you a general idea of this Hugging Face
library.
This is what we are going to need now.
So this Hugging Face library as I told you gives you access to different models that
you have those are pre-trained models, base models, instruction tuned models to get a
many type of models.
But not all the models are directly accessible to you.
If you are going to access a model you need to have an gated repository for that.
So what does this mean?
This means that I am if I am building a model and I do not want everyone to get access to
that model.
I want only specific people to get access to the model.
So for example this Lama model it has some gated repositories.
So how we can access this Lama model because we are going to use Lama models in this next
section.
So this is how you are going to do that.
You go to your Hugging Face account.
So you have to create an account here.
I think I am not going to discuss about how to create an account here.
So you can go ahead and just create your Hugging Face account.
Once you have this you can just go there so in your profile.
So here you will see that there is this user profile setting so let us make it a bigger.
So here you will see that there is a section called setting right we will go to this settings.
In the settings you will see that there is gated repositories.
So in the left hand side in the settings of Hugging Face library you will have this gated
repositories.
So here you will see that these are some of the models that I am using and that required
this gated status.
So what does this mean?
This means that I need to request access from my end that I want to use it for research
purpose or some other purpose or business purpose whatever it is.
I need to get access from that model and they can verify it manually and they can give you
an access.
So how you can do that?
Let us take an example.
So let us take an example of Lama3.
So Lama4 is the very latest model.
I am just showing you this Lama3 model.
So Meta Lama3 you can see that once you search this Lama3 you will get this Meta Lama model
here and the model name is given as Meta Lama.
So the model name then the version of the model 3 and then the parameters of the model
which is 8 billion parameters.
So previously we were using a 3 billion parameter model and this Lama is a 8 billion parameter
model.
So possibly this is a much better model than the previous one.
But in some of the task that model might outperform this also.
So let us open this.
So once we open this model you will see that you will get, so it is something written here
as gated model.
Let me zoom in.
So gated model and you have been granted access to this model.
So it is written here.
If you do not have access to this model so there will be a section here.
So let us let us just open it in a different window.
You see that here I do not have access because I have just not opened it.
So you need to agree to share your contact information to access this model.
So you have to log into this model and you have to just get access so you have to request
access giving typing some information about why you require that model to be.
This is fine.
So you get an access to gated model.
So once you get the access where you can get the information from if you are having this
access or not from here.
So here in the settings going to this gated repository section you will see the list of
the models that you have requested and the list of the models you can see that the request
status is given here.
So some of the models are accepted some are pending right.
So the models that are accepted you can use those models similar to what we have done
for the Flan T5 Excel.
For Flan T5 Excel it is not a gated model so you can use it any time.
But for Lama you need to get an access.
I think we are going to use Lama 2 or Lama 3 whatever we are using.
So for using this gated models through that hugging face library there is another additional
step that we need to perform.
So the step is to create an access token.
To create an access token you can just visit this access token section here in the settings
only and you can create a new token here.
You can see that create new token.
So you click on this create new token and you can just give a class name of the token.
So let us call the name as HAI because it is temporary token that will be removed once
this class is over.
And this is this token and I want to access this gated repository and nothing else right.
So I will just click here so read access to contents of all pipe public gated repos that
I can access.
So this gives me an access to basically a token to access those gated repositories through
my account.
So let us create this create token.
So you see that I am being given a token here.
So this is the token.
So let us copy this token and click on done.
And once you copy that token you must remember that you will not be allowed to view that
token anymore.
So I have copied it but I cannot access it anymore.
So I cannot see the token if I am not copied it properly.
So if you are missed that you can just remove that and you can create a new token for that.
So I will just place my access token here.
I will just place my access token here and these are the same libraries that we are using
but another library that we are using is pipeline and another is this bits and byte config.
We do not need this.
So transformers provides us with this pipeline and bits and byte config and I am just loading
this access token.
Let us run this.
So this access token is actually now having my access token to that gated repositories.
So we have loaded that.
Now you will see that understanding the template prompt.
So we will understand this but before that I think okay.
So this is one model but I will just show you another model.
So let me load a different model.
Let me load this model pipeline equals to this and let me explain the part.
So I am running this.
So you see that it requires you to install this bits and bytes.
So it asks me to install this.
So what I can do is I can just select it and run it using this percentage.
This is a special function probably you know of.
So if you use this you can actually directly pip install from this notebook.
So let it download first because this downloads take time.
Once it is done I will just try to load this model and I will then explain the thing.
So let us just see this part first.
What does this thing mean?
So instead of using this model and tokenizer separately we can use this pipeline.
So pipeline is nothing but a particular class provided by Huggingface the tokenizer's library
which actually combines this tokenizer and model together.
So this pipeline already has a tokenizer and a model itself.
So you do not have to load the model separately and the tokenizer separately.
In many cases in our research we find that we need to use the tokenizer separately and
model separately but in many cases we might not require it and there this pipeline can
be used directly without writing that part of the code that we have already seen.
So we do not write the model tokenizer, we do not write the model loading and all.
We just write this pipeline and we call this pipeline object using this different parameters.
So what are the parameters?
The first parameter is the task, this is the text generation task.
So this is installed, so once it is installed you will see that requirement already satisfied
and all.
So let me just try to run this part again.
So I am just importing this torch and transformers and then I will run this.
I will go through this step by step, I am just running it because it will take some time.
So here you will see that this task is basically text generation task.
So what is text generation task?
It is the task of generating new text as simple as that as we can understand here.
So this is the thing that you need to pass as a parameter.
Second is the model.
So previously we used to give this model name to the tokenizer to this model separately
and here we directly give the model name here and the model that we are using is MetaLama38b
instruct.
So this is the model that we are using.
If I search this model, if I search this model here, you can just see in the Google search
we can go to the service library, this is the model page.
If you need any information about the model you can see here it is present here.
So there are many codes also you can directly access this pipeline and all, there are so
many parameters to work with.
So let us see that this is a model which contains two different sub-models.
One is this 8 billion parameter model which we are using and another is a 70 billion parameter
model.
And I hope that you will not be able to run that because it is a very, very big model.
It will require at least like 120 GB of graphics card RAM.
So basically VRAM to load it to the memory.
And if you are using CPU probably you will not get the output because it will just take
large amount of time to give you a simple output also.
So we will use this 8 billion parameter model here.
So it is a model which is trained with data that cuts off at 2023 March.
So these are the different things you might understand.
This is the context length which is 8K.
That is basically the number of input tokens that you can give to the model.
So 8000 tokens you can give to the model.
So let us just get to this code part.
So you see that the model is loading it.
So it will take some time here.
So let us go here again.
Now we have this torch underscore D type.
So what is this torch D type?
So this is important to understand that if you are using this models you are training
this models through these parameters.
Each of these parameters are nothing but floating point numbers.
And the dimension of this floating point numbers actually if it is more then it is a better
model because you have more precision over the output over your model.
So this precision means how much, how many number of digits you are having in a general
sense.
So for example, in a model, in a model, so let us say this is a trained parameter.
So this is a trained model.
I am just considering a single trained neuron.
So a single trained neuron, let us say we consider neuron in this circle.
So we are just using this to represent let us say a 32 bit value.
You are using this represent.
So this is a single neuron or single parameter of the 7 billion parameters or 8 billion parameters,
right?
You can understand that.
So this is only one neuron.
So it is having a 32 bit size.
As I told you previously that we need to load the model to the memory or we need to load
the model to this virtual graphics memory.
So if you need to load the model, so there are 7 billion parameters.
We need to load the entire model to this VRAM.
We need to load this entire 7 billion parameter to VRAM.
We cannot chunk it.
We cannot cut it here, put it half here and half there.
So it is not possible.
We have already seen that we cannot put even some of the parts, maybe the tokenizer to
the CPU and other to the GPU.
It is not possible.
We have to have a continuous memory where we need to put this 7 billion parameter model,
right?
And the precision here is, as I told you, generally it is in 32 bits.
Once we train a model, the main model that we are using, the foundation model, it is
having a 32 bit precision.
And if you load this 7 billion parameter model, let us say it will take around 28 GBs or even
more, right?
It is generally 4 into 7, but let us consider it is having 24 GBs.
Now why this 24 GBs, because each of these neurons takes up 32 bits of data.
So it takes 32 bit of space.
Here we will see that we have written in this code that data type is B float 16.
So what does this mean?
This means that it will reduce this precision from 32 bit to 16 bit.
And this is only for this Torch data types, not for the entire model, that is also one
of the thing that we will need to see.
So you see that already you have halved the size of the entire model.
So you have halved the size of the entire model.
So you had previously 32 bit it now becomes 16 bit per neuron or per parameter.
If this is the case, then you will see that instead of 28 GBs, now I will require only
14 GBs of data of memory.
So if you had a memory of 16 GB, if your computer had a memory of 16 GB, previously with this
32 bit you will not able to load the model, but with this 16 bit parameters you will be
able to load it in a 16 GB model, in the 16 GB VRAM.
I think this makes it clear to you.
So we are reducing the precision.
Now what is the significance of reducing the precision?
Of course, the first thing is that we are able to load a mass like smaller model compared
to the original larger model of 32 bits.
Then if you see that we are using this model, which is a 16 bit model, it has reduced precision.
So the effect of this in the output will be that you will get a bit bad result.
So the generation will be not that great because you are reducing the precision to half.
So even if we are reducing the precision to half like 16 bit, we have seen that the models
have performed quite well, we are already using all the models in 16 bit precision and
you will see that they work quite fine.
So most of the time we do not require to load the model in 32 bit, 16 bit precision is fine.
But let us say you only have a 12 GB of GPU, then what is the thing?
If you only have a 12 GB of GPU memory or VRAM, then even by using the 16 bit we cannot load
it.
For that we need to use quantization.
These are very important terms because when working with large language models, this will
be the actual thing that we will be working on.
So loading the model is pretty easy, you can just get the grab the model from here and there.
But running the model in the way that you want is very very difficult and as the model
grows it becomes bigger, you will see that this becomes a much more challenging.
So quantization is again another aspect where we reduce the entire model parameters from
32 bit to whatever precision we want.
That we generally use this 8 bit precision and rarely we use a 4 bit precision and this
4 bit precision is not available to all the models that needs to be separately trained.
But for 8 bit you will find many models that are already present in 8 bit.
Now, if the model we are just 1 to 8 bit, then again you will see that you are reducing
this parameter.
So now instead of 28 GB, now 14 GB, now you are end up with only let us say 7 to 8 GB of
memory requirement.
So it can now easily fit to this 12 GB.
So if you are having this issue, you can just use quantization.
And quantization models are smaller models, so smaller models will be faster.
Since you have reduced precision, the calculations will be faster.
So the model is run faster.
But the issue here is that if you are using an 8 bit model, there is significant decline
in the output quality.
So for 32 bit to 16 bit, we do not observe very bad kind of quality in the results.
But from 16 bit to 8 bit, we see a huge dip in the like quality of outcomes.
From 8 bit to 4 bit again, as you can understand is a very very bad model.
So in rarely we use a 4 bit quantized model.
So this is the general architecture idea if you are using a large language model, if you
are going to use it in any environment.
Device map we have again kept it at auto.
Now here in this pipeline, if we are keeping this to auto, it will automatically load both
the tokenizer and this model, not separately, but together into either a CPU or a GPU, whichever
is available.
Now we have a T4 GPU, so it will in this auto mode will directly just move it to this GPU.
Or you can directly specify here CUDA 0 or GPU 1, whatever is the name of the device
that you are having.
Now you see that there is another parameter, this is this token which takes this access
token that we have created in the hugging test library.
Then there is a response, let us just break it down into this multiple section.
So I think the model is downloaded, so the model is downloaded.
Now device is set to use CUDA 0.
So once I loaded the model, you see that I have loaded the model here.
I have loaded this quantized model.
Now let us not run this part because we have already loaded the model.
So here we have discussed this quantization already.
So for quantization, we will need this bits and bytes, that is why I have installed this
bits and bytes.
So these bits and bytes give you the flexibility of using different quantized models.
So once you install it using this, you can directly use that quantization configuration.
So this is a variable that actually takes this value and we are using this bits and
bytes config class which we have loaded here, you see this bits and bytes.
Load in 8 bit equals to 2.
Now I have already told you that 8 bit models are not good but for our testing and I am
just going to show you here because we are already in a very small resource environment
in a T4 GPU.
So we are loading the model in 8 bit.
So load in 8 bit equals to 2 does give you that exact same thing that we need.
So in this pipeline, you will see that the task is again takes another, it is exactly
the same as the previous one.
But the previous one, you will see that there were no like quantization except for this
Torch data type which we have used B Float 16 which is the half precision mode.
But here you will see that we are loading the model, the same model, mapping it into
the GPU because it is in auto, access token is given and the model KWRGs actually takes
the parameter of this quantization config.
You need to run this model if you are using this collab library, collab thing here.
You just use this part of the code and not the previous one.
It will take more time to load and all.
So once we have this model ready, we can just take response from the model.
So the response, you just give the same command, the pipeline, it handles everything.
You give the input prompt which is we are calling as chat and max new token.
So this actually specify that how, what is the limit of the output tokens that you want.
I do not want for example, more than 512 tokens.
The tokens are not related to number of words, but it is a similar kind of idea.
So a word might have multiple tokens associated, right?
But I want like for example, 512 tokens and the output however I will get, I will take
this response, I will take the first dimension, generated text and we will get the content.
So we will see that why this long kind of statement, we will see that.
So let us do it in a step by step way.
So now it is going to run on the GPU because it is loaded in the GPU environment.
This pipeline, the model and the tokenizer.
So let us see what is this chat, right?
This chat is right now adjacent kind of format or a dictionary format in terms of Python
which looks something like this.
And this is very important if you are going to work with this large language models.
This chat has this role where we have given a system, this role then we have user.
So let me just go through this part.
So you see that the prompt has three different sections.
The first section is the system prompt.
The first system, the thing is the system prompt, then there is this user prompt and
then there is this assistant.
So these are the three different sections of the prompt.
So these three combines together to build the entire prompt set, right?
To give you an example of system prompt, let us see you can just tell that you are a translator
or you can say you are a travel guide, something like that.
So what does this mean, this mean that the model will direct itself or treat itself as
a translator or a travel guide.
Then user prompt, this is the prompt that you are giving.
So this is the prompt, actual prompt input from user, right?
So this is the prompt input from the user.
So this user prompt will generally be the prompt that the user gives and assistant is
nothing but the output from the model, the output from the model.
This is the structure of the prompt and how this is performed in our examples is that
you give role, the role will be the system and in that will give the content, the content
have the content.
So you are a friendly tour, travel guide whatever we call it.
Again the role is user, content is hey, can you tell me any fun things to do in New York?
So let us consider this and save it, so this is the structure of the prompt that we are
using.
The model will directly translate it and see that this is the system prompt, this is the
user prompt and it will generate the assistant prompt because it is generated by the model.
So let us use this response equals to pipeline chat MaxNewToken we have discussed and we
are just going to print that.
So let us just run this response.
So this is a pad token ID to end of sequence token ID.
So this is a padding kind of like thing that you might get in warning form, does not matter
it will automatically set it, that is why it is showing it here.
So let us just print the response whatever response we get.
Now you see it is running using the GPU then also it is taking time because the T4 GPU is
not that great, it should not have taken much time with a better GPU but for T4 it will take
some time.
So let us run this response.
So this output from this response is this.
You can see that generated text and inside this generated text we have a role system
and all.
So this is an entire list and we want what we want from this the dictionary.
So you just give response 0, this gives you this entire list.
From this entire list I need this generated text key, the value that represent.
So it is having this kind of role, content, role, content and all.
So till here.
So I take this generated text.
Then I take this minus 1 which is the last one.
So the last one is nothing but this content and the role is from this assistant.
As I told you this assistant is nothing but the output from the model.
So the output from the model comes to the role of assistant and the content is the actual
output from the model.
And from there we want this content which is the exact output.
Let us print this.
So this is basically we are doing a basic pre-processing of this thing.
You run it and you will see that we have this exact output.
Oh boy, do I have a ton of fun things to share with you.
So whatever the thing is about in here.
So you will see that this is a very general idea of how you can prompt a large language
model.
Now the fun things come here that if we want to add something to this prompt, how we can
do that.
So here let us say this is the chat, in this variable chat I am just responding my output.
So responses 0, generated text.
So in this responses 0.generate text you will see we have this entire set of values where
we have this role of system.
So this is the inter prompt, the role of the user and the role of the content.
So basically the last output from the model.
So here we have this system user assistant, this pattern.
So now as an user I want to reply something because in chat you get the output from the
model and you give the input to the model.
So for that I am just storing it in the chat and appending this an extra role which is
the user role and I am just saying wait, Statue of Liberty.
So it has given this output in here what is Statue of Liberty and all.
So I have just asked the model, Statue of Liberty.
So this is a general response that I have given and I am running the exact same pipeline.
So it will run.
So what happened now is that we already had this.
So we already had this prompt where we had the system prompt.
Then we had this user prompt, then we had this assistant prompt which makes up our one iteration.
So system prompt, user prompt, assistant prompt.
Now using this I will just add another user prompt.
So now it has this user prompt, assistant prompt and user prompt all together.
It has all together.
It will generate the next assistant prompt based on this entire sequence, based on this
entire output.
That is why we call it as a chat assistant.
As you can see the previous output from this assistant is again used by the model because
we are using it as a chat.
So here you see that the Statue of Liberty is a must see attraction in New York.
It is one of these.
So it is telling something about this Statue of Liberty where it matches the context using
this previous output generated by itself.
So here this is how we are doing.
So this is essentially what you are doing is a for loop, not for loop, it is basically
a loop.
So where you have this assistant and this user and you give this user input to this assistant.
Then you give this assistant output and you as a user give another input and this becomes
a loop and we can create a chatbot out of it, very simply.
Let us consider what is this chatbot.
So I am not going to like give a very big time to this.
So let us consider this while true.
So we are running this for loop true until an exit is given as an input to the from the
user's end and if exit is not given, anything else is given, it becomes a part of this model
output.
So let us just make my chat model, let us see what is the previous prompt.
So this is the previous prompt.
So system you are friendly to, can you tell me fun things to do in India.
So now this is, this is the prompt that I have created for now.
So enter your response.
So this is the exact same code that we have used.
What we are doing we are taking the output from the model, appending it to the interprompt
and then again running the model and all.
So let us run this, if you run this you will see that interview response.
So my response is tell me about India.
So if this is the input to the model, you will see it is going to the model prompt, it
will have the access and it will generate the output and give me the output here and
I can again like chat it.
So I think this part is over, now we will move on to this fine tuning part.
I think we can take a break of 5 minutes, then we can rejoin and you can run this particular
part of the code and see how it works.
You can use the Flan T5 model also, but for that you would not get this pipeline.
You can build it using the model and the tokenizer for yourself.
So we are going to have a break of 5 minutes.